Let me begin by just reminding us where we are and this course reminding
ourselves of what we've done and what we have yet to do.
We started by talking about the brain,
the physical basis of thought,
and then we moved to some general introductions to some foundational ideas.
In the study of psychology,
Freud and Skinner,
we spend a bit of time on more cognitive stuff,
development,
language,
vision,
memory.
Then we took a little break and the Dean told us about love.
Then we dealt with the emotions,
the emotions,
rationality in evolution and a lot of that what we learned particularly
regarding the evolution of the mind,
um,
provided supporting material for what follows.
Uh,
we learned about cognitive neuroscience using,
um,
the study of face recognition as an important case study,
human differences,
behavioral genetics,
nature,
nurture,
sex and food.
Um,
my electric was on sex.
Dr. Brown Nell came and spoke to us about food today,
mortality
next week,
social thought and social behavior
mysteries.
Basically a series of topics that don't fit anywhere in the course and really
make psychologist scratched their heads.
Um,
these topics are sleep,
laughter and religion.
Mental illness,
two lectures on madness,
what can go wrong in your minds and the last lecture on happiness.
And then you're just,
you're just done.
You know,
you know a lot of psychology and a lot of stuff and you're well prepared for
your ultimate major in psychology.
Ultimately graduate training at a good school.
Um,
how many people here are either psych majors or expect to become psych majors?
Cognitive or cognitive science is what you could raise your hand too.
Okay,
good.
It's nowhere near enough and so,
and so I'll ask the question again.
When once you deal with happiness and then mysteries,
you're really not going to want to what?
What is her chemistry?
Anthropology.
Premed.
Gimme a break.
Okay.
Um,
we're going to deal with three facets of morality.
One,
talk about moral feelings,
moral judgments,
and then moral action with particular focus on why good people do bad things.
Um,
which will lead us to review and discuss the Milgram's study,
which was presented in the movie on Monday.
Okay.
Now moral feelings
is what we'll start off with.
And we've already discussed this in a different context.
The question is how could moral feelings evolve?
So moral feelings,
we give you his feelings of um,
condemnation,
shame,
emotions like that.
Shame,
condemnation,
pride,
righteous anger,
but also simple affection,
caring for other people,
wanting to do well by them being upset if an an injustice has to be done by
them.
And you might think,
okay,
that the existence of these feelings is a mystery from it.
I'm illusionary point of view.
If evolution is survival of the fittest,
nature red in tooth and claw,
how could animals evolve?
Moral feelings.
But in fact we know the answer to this and there are two answers to this.
One answer is kin selection.
So evolution works at a level of the genes and because of that it could give
rise to animals that are themselves altruistic and they're altruistic because
they act to preserve other animals that share the same genes.
And so I'm not going to work,
I'm not gonna spend any time on this because we've discussed it in detail,
but we know from previous lectures that people will be generous to others.
And there's an evolutionary explanation for your generosity towards kin.
It can be mathematically worked out.
You're carrying your moral feelings towards other creatures to the extent of the
proportion of genes that you share with them,
okay?
The most algorithmic behavior of all giving your life to help.
Another can be explained in coldblooded evolutionary terms.
Animals that are altruistic,
even to the point of dying to help another,
those genes will under some circumstances be preserved over the genes of people
who are less caring.
And that is one force towards kindness.
A second force towards kindness is cooperation.
Even if animals are unrelated,
they are nice to one another.
Um,
animals would give warning Christ,
they will groom at one another.
They will exchange food.
Okay?
And the reason for this is that animals have evolved.
Our minds have evolved to enter into sort of cooperative situations with other
people.
And to surmount prisoner's dilemma is to surmount,
um,
deception and cheating.
This gives rise to some emotions including emotions that could be viewed as
moral emotions like guilt and anger.
And again,
grounds altruistic behavior.
In an evolutionary perspective,
this is all by means of review,
but the question you can now ask is fine.
That's why moral feelings might evolve,
but what do we know as psychologists about the emergence and nature of moral
feelings in an in,
in individuals?
What's the psychology of moral feeling?
And this is an issue I'm going to talk about now,
but I'm going to return to next week when we deal with issues such as liking and
disliking racial prejudice and other things.
But I want to deal now of a couple of interesting case studies about moral
feelings from a psychological point of view.
The first one I want to deal with is empathy and empathy has different
definitions,
but we can simply view it as
the feeling that
your pain matters to me.
If you are hurt,
that is in some sense painful for me.
If you are sad that affects my own mood.
I am not a selfish creature.
I am built,
I am hardwired to be attuned to your pain.
This is an old observation.
Adam Smith who was often falsely viewed as a proponent of selfishness and
hardheadedness.
What's quite explicit about the poll?
This has,
um,
he knows when we see a stroke aimed and just ready to fall upon the leg or arm
of another person,
we naturally shrink and drawback our own leg or arm.
And when it does fall,
we feel it in some measure and are hurt by it as well as the suffer.
If you see somebody being kicked in the Groin and a movie,
you might yourself tense up.
If you see somebody bang their their thumb with a hammer,
you might cringe.
Here's a good illustration of somebody in anticipatory pain.
Now
it's a very British base actually.
Um,
now
we know certain things about this empathy,
some which might be surprising.
The pain of others is a versa.
Even for babies,
we know this because if babies hear other babies crying,
they will get upset.
The crying of babies is a verse of two babies.
Now,
some of you may be sufficiently cynical to say that could be explained in other
ways.
For one thing,
one theory is that babies hear other babies cry because babies are so stupid.
They think they themselves are crying.
If they're crying,
they must be in some sort of pain so they cry some more.
But clever psychologist have ruled this out.
What they did was a study where they expose babies to tape recorded sounds of
other babies crying and tape recorded sounds of themselves.
Babies crying more to this pain of other babies than they do to their own pain,
suggesting that their response is to some extent a response to the otherness of
the characters we know pain is of others is a verse of for Chimpanzees,
and we know this in certain ways,
but we know this in particular from a series of studies that would be unethical
if they were to be done today.
In these studies,
they put a chimpanzee in a room and there's a lever and when the chimpanzee
slaps to lever,
it gets some food.
Trivial,
smart animal piece of cake,
but the room has a window leading to another room and another room.
Another chimpanzee has placed this second chimpanzee is not a relative of the,
of the,
of the first chimpanzee and they've never seen each other before.
Now when the first chimpanzee hits the Lever,
the second chimpanzee gets a painful electric shock.
Putting the first Champan Z in a horrible dilemma in order to feed themselves.
He has a torture and other animal.
Chimpanzees do not starve themselves to death.
It's very unlikely any of you would either,
but they go along time without food suggesting that you do not want to cause
this other chimpanzee pain.
Um,
it only works within species.
So in another experiment,
they put a rabbit in the other room and a chimpanzee would slap the lever
repeatedly to make the rabbit scream in pain and jump.
Um,
now
we've known for a long time that empathetic feeling is not logically linked to
morality.
This is a point made by Aristotle.
I could see you writhing in pain that could cause me pain,
but it doesn't mean I'm going to be nice to you.
I could run away from you,
I can turn my head or I can blame you for causing me this misery.
But it does happen that emotional that,
that this sort of empathy does lead to moral concern and action.
Um,
if we do an experiment and we induce you to feel empathetic to somebody,
we get you to feel what they're feeling.
You're more likely to be nice to them.
And people differ in the extent to which they feel empathy.
Um,
people defer to the extent it will hurt them to watch me slam my thumb with a,
with a hammer.
If you are a high empathy,
you're more likely to be a nice person than if you're low empathy.
Suggesting there's some connection between empathetic feeling and liking.
Now,
empathetic feeling like any other human capacity differs across people.
Some of us have a lot of it.
Some of us don't have much of it there.
Some reason to believe that in a population known as psychopaths,
a population we'll return to later on when we discuss illness.
Um,
this sort of instinctive empathy is broken and the pain of others just doesn't
bother them very much.
Um,
I asked him illustrative quotes here.
the Damon's book a wonderful book on psychopathy.
He talks about a 13 year old McGraw who specialized in mugging blind people.
And when asked about the pain,
he caused his victims,
he responded,
what do I care?
I'm not her,
which is logically correct,
but in a sense in human,
the fact that it's another person should make you care.
The serial killer,
Gary Gilmore basically said the pain of others gratified him and caused him no
unhappiness at all.
I was always capable of murder.
I can become totally devoid of feelings of others unemotional.
I know I'm doing something grossly and here it is a very bad word wrong.
I can still go ahead and do it.
And Ted Bundy when interviewed at one point said he was astonished that people
made such a fuss about all of his murders because he said,
I mean there are so many people
and if any of you here are nodding in agreement that these sentiments,
that's not such a good sign.
These are,
these are particularly callous and cold leaded statements suggesting that is
instinctive empathy.
This aspect of moral thought is not,
um,
is present in most of us but not in all of us.
The second case study of moral feeling,
its ingroup and outgroup in our,
in our affections,
in our,
in our caring who we like,
who we feel close to,
who's pain bothers us.
We are not indiscriminate.
I care a lot more about my children than I do about my friends and I care more
about my friends and I care about strangers.
We're all like that.
We also favor our group over others in every possible way.
You are a member of many groups.
You are men,
you are women,
you're Yale students,
you're young,
you're,
you're white,
you're black,
you're Asian,
you're member of these groups.
And as we will discuss repeatedly,
um,
when we talk about social cognition and social behavior,
this membership matters a lot to you.
What's particularly interesting is even groups that are formed that you're not
born with,
that are formed on the fly exert a huge amount of control over your moral
feelings and moral attitudes.
And that the best example of this is discussed in detail in the textbook.
And this is the robber's cave study.
And this robber's cave study serves as a nice illustration of morality in
everyday life.
Um,
the study was 11 and 12 year old boys at a camping program.
These were well adjusted pretty kids,
racially homogeneous,
and they were putting a separate cabins and the cabins were given leaders and
they gave themselves names being unimaginative.
Boys,
they call themselves the eagles and the rattlers.
But the,
as what happened was being separated,
they developed distinctive cultures
and
when these groups were set in competition against each other,
the eagles versus the rattlers,
the within group intensity grew,
eagles began,
eagles began to care a lot more about other eagles than about anybody else.
Um,
so there's within group solidarity and then there were negative stereotypes.
so these groups develop different cultures.
It was a randomly cut apart,
kind of like Yale College is actually where you got a random assortment of
people.
But despite the fact that the assortment is random,
the division is random,
cultures begin to emerge.
The eagles prided themselves on being clean,
living,
not using cuss words and treating each other with respect.
They viewed the rattlers as dirty and tough and kind of Slovenly slobs.
Um,
the rattlers viewed the eagles as Goodie,
Goodie kids.
Um,
it's cruel.
Finally,
it all devolves into hostilities,
raid rates and violence.
Um,
the eagles burnt or rattlers banner cuss words were occasionally used.
And so Sharif the expert,
a psychologist designing all of this when,
you know,
excellent.
And,
and then the problem,
he then says,
now we've created,
we've created two different warning cultures.
That was fun.
What do we do to make them friends again?
And then we figured how to now we've done that.
Then this whole solve all sorts of problems.
So they started off,
they wanted to have a,
they said a peace talks were representative of the Eagle and a representative
rattler.
Um,
we're set to meet and plan a ways to,
they get,
you know,
disarm and stop using cuss words and everything like that.
Um,
this failed.
The kids who engaged in the peace talks were ostracized by their own groups as,
as treasonous.
That failed.
They decided to set up individual competitions like the Olympics where they
would,
people wouldn't compete as eagles or rattlers,
but rather,
um,
they would compete as individuals that fail to like the Olympics.
People.
The teams took the readability.
They took their individual accomplishments as reflecting on,
on,
on the group,
and it devolved into eagles versus the rattlers.
They shared meals.
They turned it,
which turned into food fights and more cuss words.
They shared movies,
more fights,
more cuss words.
They share fun with firecrackers,
which,
which was a disastrous thing,
was nearly brought the experiment to an end.
They brought in a religious figure to give them sermons on brotherly love.
The sermons were entirely unsuccessful.
Um,
what,
what's interesting is they did the Eagle.
They took them to heart.
These were good kids.
They were respectful of religious authority,
but the lessons they took from him as I should learn to love my neighbor,
if I'm a rattler,
I should learn to love my fellow rattler and appreciate him as a fellow writer,
as a person.
I love him.
His love nonlegal scummy eagles.
Um,
they all failed.
Here's what worked.
Sharif told the kids,
all of the kids that the water line to the camp was cut
and they all had to defend the camp.
What does dad did was it established a superordinate goal?
That is a goal that everybody shared and perhaps more important,
a common enemy.
This is where the solution,
by the way to bringing together,
and you could write this down to bringing together all the warning countries and
religions of this planet is an alien attack by the logic of the sheer,
even who all bring us all together as a group.
Um,
and different question is there.
In that experiment,
the groupiness was established in a very powerful way.
They live separately.
They interacted with each other.
They had their own names.
The psychologist Taj fell after World War II was interested in the question of
what could make a group.
In other words,
what do we have to do to you to put you in a different group from him?
What do we have to do to this class,
this side of the class,
to put you in a different group from this side and different from that site.
And what would it have to do for those groups to matter,
such that,
for instance,
if I separate you in one group and you are another group and I give you $100,
will you give the money more to him or to him?
Will you give it more to your own group?
Our to another group.
And what he found was,
um,
you don't need much.
In one experiment he showed people pictures of modern art and based on their
responses he described him as Chloe lovers or Kandinsky lovers.
And this is all made up.
They were just random assignment.
But the Cli lovers viewed themselves as more similar to other key lovers.
They thought the key Lubbers headed to be smarter than to convince the lovers
and the clean levers,
um,
would devote more resources to themselves than to others.
This is why it's called minimal groups.
You don't need much to make you into a group.
Um,
and in fact later experiments just flipped the coin.
So the line,
the experiment goes like this.
I ask everybody was glad to take out a coin.
You all flip it.
Everyone who's heads,
you're one group,
everyone who tails,
you're neither group.
Then I ask people in the heads group,
which group do you put yourself aside?
Which group on average?
You think a smarter.
It was like,
well,
you know,
kind of works out that the heads group is Kinda really smear to heads,
smart.
Um,
which group?
Here's some money you have to distribute it.
You're more likely,
it's a subtle,
it's a subtle effect when you make the groups so minimal,
but you're more likely to give it to your own group then to others.
And this suggests that moral feelings are exquisitely attuned,
not necessarily only to individuals but also to the psychology of groups.
Okay.
Any questions at this point about moral feelings?
Yes.
How was that?
It's morality and Beers on morality because it bears on.
The question is how does group membership,
how does that relate to the topic of morality?
And the answer is the moral feelings.
We're talking about our feelings,
like empathy and caring.
For me to have a moral feeling towards you means you matter to me.
If you were to be harmed,
I would do it as wrong.
And the group experiments suggest that the extent to which these moral feelings
operate are partially determined by the groups to which we belong to.
Um,
if I'm American and you are from another country,
I will view myself.
This is a very kind of obvious finding my obligations to you will be seen as
less than if you were another American.
If I'm a clea lover and you're a Kandinsky lover,
I don't think you quite deserve as much as me.
Moral judgment is an area that is tremendously exciting.
And there's a lot of recent research on this.
Um,
by moral judgment,
I mean not empathetic feelings,
not feelings of caring and love our approval and disapproval.
So not feelings of caring and love and empathy,
but notions like something is good or bad,
something like something is fair or unfair.
So there were three hallmarks for moral judgments.
So I suppose I say I don't like strawberry ice cream.
That's an evaluation.
That's a judgment,
but it's not a moral judgment.
Why not?
Because I don't think it carries a sense of obligation.
I don't think anybody's obliged to eat or not eat strawberry ice cream and it
doesn't carry a notion of sanctions.
Meaning I don't think anybody should be punished for reading strawberry ice
cream.
On the other hand,
um,
if I say I don't like baby killers,
that actually is a moral judgment in my case.
So it's not me.
I said,
well,
I don't like baby killers.
You'd like to kill babies.
I actually think we are obliged not to kill babies.
If you disagree with me,
you're wrong and you should stop killing those babies.
Should you fail to stop killing those babies?
I think you should be punished for killing babies.
And that's what my judgment about.
No killing babies makes it a moral judgment.
Now,
some people are tempted to look at this the wrong way and say,
look,
what a weird topic.
Morality.
I don't believe in morality.
I believe in Nietzsche.
I don't believe in where I,
I don't believe in ethics.
Um,
but I don't believe you if you were to say that because morality isn't morality
as we talk about it in this context isn't just regarding your position on big
questions like political issues or,
um,
or big moral questions like abortion or capital punishment rather.
Some sort of moral judgment happens all the time,
often unconsciously.
Um,
so as you live your life,
you have to answer questions like,
what should you eat anymore of vegetarians here
I'm just raising my hand to encourage people.
Okay.
Anybody give to charity?
Anybody not give to charity?
Good.
Different from the moral vegetarians I noticed.
Um,
who do you socialize with?
There's homeless people around Yale and new haven.
What do you give to them?
You avoid their eyes.
Do you,
um,
what do you want to do with your life?
Who you have sex with?
Under what context or conditions?
These are moral questions.
Um,
I view my favorite moral dilemma is as I'm walking down the street and I see
somebody,
I sort of know,
do I like avoid eye so I don't have a conversation or do I say,
hey,
how are you doing?
Or do I kind of do the nod hoping that there won't be more than this nod?
And then after I leave and I say,
oh,
I should have made eye contact that person,
I'm such a jerk.
There's a homeless person.
And,
but these are day to day moral questions we struggle with all the time.
And so,
so there's a sense [inaudible] in the study of how we do moral reasoning.
So what do we know about more reasoning?
Well,
we know that there are some universals are some aspects of more reasoning that
show up everywhere on earth.
And there's some evidence though it's not particularly strong at this point,
that the same intuition show up in young children and a nonhuman primates like
chimpanzees,
capuchins,
macaques and so on.
And these are things like anger at cheaters,
gratitude toward sharers,
the sort of things you'd expect to come out in a prisoner's dilemma.
Um,
feelings that some things are right and some things are wrong and these are
foundational.
But at the same time the study of more reasoning is a fascinating,
fascinating issue for those of us interested in cross cultural psychology cause
there are playing differences across cultures.
So the anthropologist Richard Schwayder gives a list here of human differences.
People have found it quite natural to be spontaneously appalled.
L rage and digging,
indignant,
proud,
disgusted,
guilty and ashamed by all sorts of things.
Then there's a long list.
Masturbation,
homosexuality,
sexual abstinence,
polygamy,
abortion,
circumcision,
corporal punishment,
capital punishment,
Islam,
Christianity,
Judaism,
capitalism,
democracy,
flag burning,
mini skirts,
long hair,
no her here,
blah,
blah.
Parents and children sleeping in the same bed.
Parents and children not sleeping in the same bed.
Women being allowed to work,
women not being allowed to work.
If I put it down in a list and got people to tick it off,
what you all thought there will be some differences.
Some of you think mediating is okay.
Some of you do not.
Some of you,
you might have different views about divorce.
Um,
most of you believe women should be allowed to work.
most of you will be,
will be in favor or not morally a scolding of homosexuality.
You'll be lukewarm about polygamy.
Nobody would like abstinence and so on.
But,
but if we gave that same list,
the people in a different culture,
they take off entirely different things.
These are ways in which people vary.
I don't think people vary in their feelings about baby killing.
I don't think he'd people vary.
But the feelings of I do something for you and then you don't,
you don't do something for me.
I think that's gut level hardwired,
evolve to solve prisoners dilemmas.
But these are important issues and these vary a lot from culture to culture.
And a good theory of psychology has to explain how these differences arise.
And Schwayder has a theory which is quite interesting.
Schwayder argues that there are three styles of thought,
three different,
um,
frameworks and moral thought.
Three different ethics.
There's an ethics of autonomy.
This is what moral philosophers within our culture of you as morality,
notions of rights,
of equality,
of freedom,
but many cultures focused on an ethics of community,
bringing together duty status,
hierarchy and interdependence.
Other cultures focused more on an ethics of divinity where notions such as
purity,
sanctity,
pollution,
and sin are relevant.
So for example,
um,
when we're talking about the rights of men and women and what they should be
allowed to do,
many people in our society following an ethics of autonomy will argue that they
should have equal rights in all domains of behavior.
Since they're there,
sentient free creatures,
they should have a right to do whatever they want unless there's a compelling
argument against it.
And the compelling argument would have to involve some infringement of the
freedom of other people.
On the other hand,
if you're in an ethics of community,
you might argue that men and women have different rights and different
responsibilities.
They may be born to perform certain things and as such are duty bound to follow
them.
If you're from an ethics of divinity,
you may appeal to religious injunctions against certain actions and behaviors.
Um,
and these may differentially restrict the behavior of men and women.
You might believe,
for instance,
that women should not prepare food when men's grading because it would
contaminate the food.
You may believe that there's,
there's severe restrictions about who could have sex with one another that don't
have to do with human rights and human freedom.
It has to do with the way things should be.
Um,
because of issues of pollution and sin.
Now,
western cultures,
as I said,
are highly invested in an ethics of autonomy.
And so the Bates we have in our culture tend to be framed in terms of an ethics
of autonomy.
If we have a debate about abortion in this class,
people what some people might say,
look,
the fetus is ascension being and as such,
it has a right to um,
to survive and shouldn't be killed by its mother.
Other people would argue,
no,
a woman has full freedom over her own body and as long as the fetus is within
the body they had,
she has a right to control it.
If we're arguing about hate speech,
we could talk about the balance between the rights of freedom of speech versus
the right to a certain quality of education,
free of harassment and humiliation.
Those are the way we frame things.
But one of the more interesting discoveries in this field is that although
people think that they're governed by the ethics of autonomy,
even people within our culture,
even highly educated people within our culture,
even people like you show moral judgments that are not quite as simple.
So this is the work of Jonathan Heit at University of Virginia.
And I'd find if you ask people,
they believe in our culture that it holds to an ethics of autonomy.
It doesn't harm anyone.
It's okay.
So if I was to ask you your attitudes about sex,
most of you,
not all of you come from different cultures.
You have different attitudes,
but most of you would say sex between consenting adults is okay.
As long as nobody gets hurt.
Um,
as long as nobody gets hurt,
people's rights are,
are respected.
So gay marriage for instance,
or gay sex would be okay with you because,
um,
it is,
it is nobody is harmed and these are consenting adults.
Hight points out that there are certain problems.
His argument,
and he illustrates this problems,
these problems with stories like this.
Julian,
mark are brother and sister are traveling together in France on summer vacation
from college one night.
They are staying alone in a cabin near the beach.
They decided it would be interesting and fun if they tried making love.
At the very least it would be a new experience for each of them.
Julie was already taking birth control pills,
but mark uses a condom too,
just to be safe.
They both enjoy making love,
but they decide not to do it again.
They keep that night a special secret which makes them feel even closer to each
other.
What do you think about that?
Was it okay for them to make love
who says yes?
Good.
And also be able to say,
yeah,
shoot her hands and they look around in astonishment that no one else has
who says no.
Hey,
who's not sure?
You're not sure?
That's the weirdest of all
pipelines,
that the distribution,
even among this,
if you look,
if you go home and you ask and you ask your parents,
he said,
Ooh,
what is,
what are you learning at Yale?
MMM.
This is a very unusual culture.
And where some people will say it's okay,
what height finds is most people say it doesn't.
And then he simply asked them being good psychologist,
okay,
what's wrong with it?
And this is the brother,
sister case.
And the responses are interesting because people view themselves as committed to
an ethics of autonomy.
They can't just say it's disgusting.
So they exhibit what height describes his moral dumbfounding meaning that they
struggle to find an explanation.
They say it's terrible because they'll have a kid and the kid will grow up
freaky and then the experiment,
or it's an interview situation says,
well,
no,
remember they're both using a lot of birth control.
Uh,
maybe she's under age,
no,
not underage.
And finally it's just wrong.
Similarly,
um,
another one,
the scenarios,
this isn't as bad as you might expect.
The family dog is playing outside and gets hit by a car.
They bring it in and they say,
oh,
Fido's dead Fido's dead,
but what's for dinner?
So they cook it and eat it.
Who says it's okay?
Good.
Who says it's not okay?
Okay.
Then they notice,
then they notice that their toilet is kind of dirty,
but whoa,
there's an American flag.
They then use the toilet to clean the flag.
Who says that's okay?
Anyway,
I think it's not okay.
And this keep in mind,
we're getting sorta even and responses here,
here on all of these.
The majority of people who are not college students in elite university say,
oh,
that's so wrong.
Finally there's this one and this one really is as bad as one might expect.
Um,
the guy is lonely,
so
purchases a frozen chicken from the supermarket,
brings it home and has relations with it.
Then he cooks it and eats it.
This is,
this is a scientific paper and psych review.
Okay.
Who says that's okay?
And I noticed,
and I noticed there's
consistency among among people.
The people think it's okay.
Um,
have every right to say that they believe,
if they really sincerely believe,
okay,
they are committed to an ethics of autonomy.
Those of you who think it's not okay,
none of these should ask yourself why
and should then scrutinize your reasons.
People are very smart and they could present easily presented reasons why they
can say,
oh,
a disease.
But these reasons tend not to be sincere.
If you take away the considerations that the reaction stays.
And these are then interesting case studies of how our moral judgment is
governed by factors that we might not conscious of.
Our moral intuitions can surprise us
milligrams.
The motivation for Milgram's work,
and this is the final thing we'll talk about in the context of morality.
uh,
was the Holocaust and he was interested in exploring why such a thing could
happen.
Yeah,
I should know by the way,
you,
you know,
for an a movie that Milgrom was uh,
was a Yale professor.
He,
um,
he left Yale when he didn't get tenure,
moved to Harvard,
didn't get tenure there too.
Um,
he was,
he had a reputation by then as a mad doctor.
He ended up,
uh,
at City University of New York,
became a full professor at,
um,
at age 33,
died in his early fifties.
Uh,
did not lead a good life,
but had extraordinary discoveries.
Another discovery,
which we'll talk about next week is has anybody heard the phrase six degrees of
separation?
Milgrom and we'll talk about that later.
Um,
Milgrom had a powerful imagination.
Okay,
so we know this.
This is all review.
There's the guy.
How many of you laughed when you saw the movie?
Interesting question.
Why?
And we'll talk about that a little while.
Um,
shocks spite,
shock to x,
x,
X.
There's,
this is just repeating what you've seen.
Um,
the learner protest as he's being shocked more and more,
but the experimenter continues to request obedience.
Um,
for those of you who haven't seen the movie,
again,
the setup is someone has a subject they don't know.
They think that they're teaching somebody in a memory game.
But actually the person who is being shocked is a confederate confederate who is
trained to react in certain ways as he's being increasingly shocked.
And the finding is that the majority of people will deliver a fatal shocks that
as person who they had never met based on the instructions of another person.
Now there's some immediate bad explanations for this.
One explanation is,
um,
these are really strange people.
These are an a normal group of psychopaths,
but we know that's not true.
It's been replicated with many subjects.
There was no reason to believe that the subjects it Milgram's original study,
um,
we're in any way unusual.
It's also a misreading to say that people are in general sadistic.
You remember from the movie,
nobody got pleasure from giving the shocks.
They felt acutely uncomfortable,
embarrassed,
conflicted under a huge amount of stress.
They weren't liking doing this.
There were follow up studies.
This is the original study.
If you take it away from Yale,
some of the authority goes away.
And similarly the extent to which there are fatal shocks goes down.
Um,
if the teacher is with the learner next,
next to him,
it goes down.
If you have to put the guy's hand on it,
you're less likely to kill them.
Uh,
if the experiment or it gives you instructions by phone,
you're less likely to do it.
If an ordinary man,
not the guy in a white lab coat but in ordinary guy says,
hey,
keep shocking and that's okay,
you're less likely to do it.
And if there's a rebellion,
if somebody else rebels is,
I won't do it.
You are much more likely not to do it yourself.
There are some,
oh sorry.
Yeah.
And if you could get to choose your own shock level,
you be keep looking then very,
very few people go all the way.
So these are an important list of factors as to the factory that can make
somebody less likely to bring it up to the killing level.
And as a rule,
we can look at those factors and think about what is the perfect situation for
making somebody do something like this.
And the perfect situation,
not to some more serious critiques in Milgram's
Milgram's experiment is why we have human subjects committees.
This is a terribly stressful experiment to do to people.
And as I say now,
but a lot of studies I described this class,
it would not today be done.
Um,
people did say they were happy to have participated and only 2% said that they
were sorry,
but,
um,
but still serious damage could have been done and,
and perhaps was done.
These people left the lab having learned about themselves,
they'll kill another person if someone tells him to.
And
as psychologists,
I don't think we have any right to do that to people.
I think people can learn new things about themselves.
We have no right to put you in a circumstance where you believe you killed
somebody and then tell you it was just pretend we just made you kill somebody.
Okay.
And that's a serious ethical criticism.
Historians and sociologists have rotten things back to the questions that,
um,
that Melbourne was interested in and argued.
Um,
and this is controversial,
the to which obedience really is a good model for acts of genocide.
Um,
so just to take one example among many,
uh,
goal hog and argued that the participants in,
um,
in Nazi Germany and in the Holocaust,
we're actually not people who were obediently following orders,
but rather we're enthusiastic people who volunteered to do it.
Still.
Milgram's work is interesting in many for many reasons in large part because he
provides an illustration of the perfect situation for getting somebody to do a
terrible thing and a perfect situation has certain ingredients.
It includes,
um,
authority,
in this case,
the authority of Yale and the authority of science.
This is an experiment that must go on.
Okay.
The notion of a self assured experimenter,
the results would be very different if the experimenter himself seem nervous,
unwilling to proceed,
confused.
But he was confident and he kept saying that he will take responsibility.
There was distance between the learner and experimenter recall,
you get less of an effect if you have to touch the guy.
But distance makes it easier for you to kill him.
And finally there's a new situation.
And no model of how to behave.
Um,
one of the reasons why the Milgram experiment is so nice to know is that if this
ever happens to you,
not as an experiment,
but in real life,
it will no longer be new to you.
You'll know what sort of thing this is and you'll be able to examine it in that
light.
I want to end this lecture,
summing up,
drawing a lot upon Milgrom and some other work and talk first about two forces
for evil and in the end,
by talking about two forces for good.
The first force for evil is d individuation of self.
And what this means is,
MMM,
one reason why people are so bad and groups is because you could diffuse your
responsibility.
If I'm running through the street alone with a baseball bat,
smashing through windows,
it's me and I know it's me.
If I'm with 20 other people,
it's not me anymore.
It's part of the group and I don't feel as bad.
Responsibility becomes diffused.
One of the powers of a group then is it diminishes responsibility.
You could diminish responsibility in other ways.
Another way of diminishing responsibility is you could accept orders.
It's not me.
I'm just an instrument of somebody else telling me what to do.
And yet,
another way of diminishing responsibility is anonymity.
Here's a question.
In so many violent acts in so many people,
gold go to war,
what they do is they paint their faces or they put on masks.
Why?
Well,
there's anonymity from others.
If I'm wearing a mask,
as I do my terrible stuff,
nobody will know it's me.
But there's also a psychological liberating effect.
If I'm anonymous,
it's not me.
And I could do terrible things were feeling the same moral responsibility.
This analysis has explained why people don't always help others in need.
If there was a group responsibility to help decreases,
and this is captured in different ways,
but the main idea is we all think someone else will help.
Um,
so we don't,
there's a diffusion.
This just summarizes some studies,
some famous studies,
uh,
supporting this.
And the classic example,
which is discussed in detail in the textbook is the cat kitty Genovese case
where somebody was murdered.
Uh,
in the common law that apartment building surrounded while dozens of people
watched dozens of good normal people watched and did nothing.
Um,
if there's some advice I've heard on this,
which is pretty good advice,
if you're ever in a predicament on a city street,
you know,
you have a heart attack,
you broke your leg,
you're being mugged and everything.
And there's,
this is based on a research.
Screaming help is often not very successful because if I'm with 10 people and
there's somebody screaming help,
I look up the other nine people,
they're not doing anything.
They're looking at me,
I'm not doing anything.
We keep walking.
What is useful is point to somebody and say you in the green sweater,
call the police.
And the psychological evidence is if you,
if somebody,
if I'm wearing a green sweater and somebody asked me to call these,
I will call the police.
I'm a good guy.
I,
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't sit aside when somebody is being harmed.
On the other hand,
if somebody says,
somebody called the police,
well,
I got things to do.
And so,
um,
the fusion of responsibility explains both when we're willing to do terrible
things and also when we're willing to,
to help people who are in trouble,
denigration of others.
There's a lot of ways to make other people matter less.
So this is the flip side,
the way to do terrible things.
One way to do terrible things is to lose yourself as,
so you're not an individual anymore.
But another way to do terrible things is so that the person you're doing it too
isn't an individual.
How do you do that?
Well,
you have psychological distance or physical distance.
I'm more likely to kill you if you're very far away.
Then if your close,
I don't,
I could describe you and start to think about you not as a person.
And language can be used for this.
Instead of people.
You can use terms like cargo instead of murder,
extermination.
Humor is very powerful in denigrating and demoting people.
When you start laughing at somebody,
you think of them as less of a person.
And we'll get to that a little bit more.
When we talk about laughter,
you would take away their names.
One of the more interesting things in the United Nations Declaration of Human
Rights is a very interesting,
right?
It says every person has a right to a name and you might think what a strange
But there's a cleverness to it.
When you take away some of these name,
they matter less people have named people have distinct individual names that
that that mark them as people.
And once you know somebody's name,
you're less likely to do bad things to them.
And another option which I'm interested in from the standpoint of my own
research is you could see them as disgusting.
Okay?
Discussed is what Paul Rosin has called the body and soul emotion.
And we know certain things about discuss.
It is a human universal,
okay?
It is a basic emotion with a characteristic facial expression.
Remember Paul Ackman's work on the basic emotions and universals of emotional
expression,
um,
discussed is one of them
and it is universally elicited by certain things like this list.
Wherever you go,
feces,
urine,
blood vomit,
rotten flesh and most meat will be disgusting.
Okay.
Now if that was all we had to say about discussed,
it wouldn't affect morality very much,
but we know that people can be seen as disgusting.
And Charles Darwin actually who was an astute observer of Human Behavior,
tells a nice story that illustrates this.
How a native touch with his fingers.
I'm cold preserve meat and playing the show.
Disgusted the softness whilst the,
I felt utter disgust in my food being touched by a naked savage,
though his hands did not appear nerdy.
People can be disgusting.
Um,
and if people are seen as disgusting,
they matter less.
The philosopher and legal scholar,
Martha Nussbaum nicely summarizes this.
Thus throughout history,
certain discuss properties have repeatedly in Manassas,
Lehman associated with Jews,
women,
homosexuals,
untouchables,
lower class people.
All of those are imagined as tainted by the dirt of the body.
Um,
any,
I won't read this,
but this is a,
uh,
a typical bit of Nazi propaganda.
Any genocidal movement that has left behind a written record,
um,
has been shown to use the mechanism of disgust to dehumanize people and make
them easier to kill.
Skip that.
Um,
I want to end though on a positive note and a positive note,
our forces for good so forces for bad or are to lose yourself as an individual.
Lose yourself in a crowd,
lose yourself because there's some authority using you as an instrument.
Lose yourself cause you're anonymous.
Plus treat others not as people as numbers,
as objects,
as disgusting things,
but there are some forces for good.
Um,
these include contact and interdependence with this often is what is,
can be viewed as,
as an extended version of selfish gene theory,
which is that to the extent you are interconnected with other people,
you care about the more for purely selfish reasons.
Um,
Robert Wright presented us in a very blunt way,
but I think his quote is quite moving.
One of the many reasons I don't want to bomb the Japanese is that they built my
minivan.
And the idea is he has economic co-dependencies people.
There are different group,
he might want to kill them under normal circumstances.
But the inner dependence,
it gives rise to a moral connection.
Um,
Thomas Friedman proposed the Golden Arches theory of human conflict,
which said that no two countries which each have a Mcdonald's will ever go to
war because Mcdonald's forces global interdependence.
This was falsified,
uh,
in the NATO bombing of I think Siri Evo,
but still his heart's in the right place.
The idea is that India connection makes you more likely to get along with other
people
more generally.
There's what's been called the contact hypothesis.
So interdependence is one thing,
but what's maybe more interesting is that simple contact with other people,
particularly if are of equal status.
You have a common goal and you have social support makes you like people more.
There are now dozens,
probably hundreds of studies that show that people who would otherwise show
animosity towards one another like blacks and whites in the United States like
each other more.
If they're brought together and there's a lot of social psychology research as
to the conditions in which you have to bring them together.
Um,
the robber's cave study talked about,
it's a nice example.
It was not easy to bring them together,
but when they had a common goal that brought them,
that that caused the interconnection and then the contact led to moral feeling.
The military is a superb example.
The military United States was a situation which brought together people who
wouldn't otherwise have any contact and they liked each other.
There's been study after study showing that people in the military or otherwise,
for instance,
racist after working with people of different races,
like the more because you had all of the right ingredients you had to have,
they worked together for a common goal.
The military supported bringing these people together.
Um,
and they were brought together on an equal and fair footing.
There was of course a lot of debate about universities like Yale to the extent
which they promote interdependence and starting to update,
promote a positive contact between groups.
And you could think of yourself as an exercise if these are the conditions for,
for um,
for contact.
To what extent are they met in a university setting between say blacks and
whites,
uh,
people from the American south versus people from American north,
people from other countries versus people from the United States.
And I know there's debate on campus about the extent to which your segregation
within the Yale community and you could ask yourself to extended,
extended that segregation and how that reflects what role it should play with
regard to the contact hypothesis.
Finally,
and this is the last thing I'll say,
if you take another's person perspective,
you'll care more about them.
This is the final force for good from a moral perspective.
Um,
JFK when making the plea for equal rights didn't produce an abstract
philosophical argument,
but rather are tried to invite his listeners who were white to engage in
perspective taking if an American,
because the skin is dark,
can not eat lunch in a restaurant,
open to the public and so and so and so.
And then who among us would be content to have the color of his skin change in
stand in his place.
Who among us would be content with the councils of patients and and delay.
Again,
Nussbaum goes on and talks about how in Greek dramas,
Greek dramas invited people to take the perspectives of those who they would
never imaginably B or even be in contact with and argue that this gave led to an
empathetic expansion.
I think one of the greatest circles for moral good is storytelling where you're
invited to take the perspective of another and see the world as they do.
Finally
do our direct ways you can ask people,
and this is the way which we talk to our children when we try to get our
children to expand their moral concern of compassion.
We say try to see it from their point of view.
How would you feel if vendor is indirect ways?
You can,
for instance,
use the power of metaphor.
There could be familiar things,
um,
that you are close to and you could bring in together new things as falling
under the rubric of these familiar things.
Uh,
so if I want it to cause you to feel more concerned for a fetus,
I would do well to describe it as a preborn child.
If I wanted you to care about an animal,
I would do well to describe it as if it were human.
Um,
if I wanted to think about all of you and get you and establish more of a
connection with you,
I would not describe you as,
you know,
unrelated strangers rather you are my brothers and my sisters and of course any
political movement and tries to bring together people together,
says uses a family metaphor.
Um,
finally,
uh,
when Steven Spielberg tried to get us to,
um,
to entertain the notion that computers and robots are sentient moral beings,
he did not show us one that looked like this.
He showed us one that looked like that.
Okay.
The reading response for next week is a simple one.
I know I've been giving difficult reading responses.
This is simple.
You could write it up very short and that will be a passing grade.
If you just read up very short,
you could also write it up a bit longer.
Suppose the Milgrim express had never been done and it was being done for the
first time here.
What would you do?
What do you think everyone else would do?
Okay,
I'll see you next week.